a bit about this tool that we wrote a
continuum it's an open source tool
called odo so if there's any Star Trek
fans hopefully you enjoy that reference
so it's a nice tool that we use a lot
actually I use it every day nearly every
day for a lot of the work that I do so
it's really about this kind of system
yeah i think the microphones on i have
to be right here okay awkward to me not
a motivational speaker yeah okay so I
think so so Phillips here he's one of
the main core developers of odo we like
to think of it as kind of CP for data
but for me it's making my life Les
Miserable it's kind of how I'm gonna set
up this talk it's going to be a little
bit negative i hope to not bring
everybody down too much sort of i'm not
really going to commit to that but
entirely so I'm been usually Kwazii been
everywhere I work for continuum so I do
some data science I do some software
development among some other things and
this is kind of what a lot of us
experience in our day-to-day life this
misery of converting data moving data
converting then moving data it's a kind
of it's the thing that we don't want to
be doing but it's what a lot of people
pay good money to do so we we push on to
on to our data scientists kind of this
cognitive load we were talking a little
bit about this at dinner so we say I
would like to hire data scientists I
want all of this to fit inside of one
person's head that's a lot there's
there's way more than this right so so
we want not only to fit inside
everybody's head but be the experts be
experts and all these kinds of things
you hire a new data person I knew a new
data scientists and they need to be able
to do some modeling so you call it
psychic learn they need to be able to
work with whatever your current
up is so right now it might be pi tables
or it might be just a bunch of CSVs and
as your data grows or as your company
grows luckily or hopefully you might
move over to a database you might move
over to these larger analytics tensions
and then you just keep on pushing more
and more knowledge into that one person
and that's that can be difficult so
maybe you hire a data engineer and then
they kind of can cut off the scientific
computing maybe but it's still good for
them to know about it they still have to
exist in this distributed systems world
in this database world and still collect
all this information inside of their
head so it kind of looks like this right
this is the textbook that you'd have to
to if you went to school that's what
with the data science textbook might
might look like so Daniels wanna so he's
right there with his hand up he's also
somebody that's trying to exit out of
misery oopsie um this is him right and
for those that remember Susan Powter you
know stop the insanity so we're so odo
is a tool that maybe can help me with
some of these things maybe and there's
actually like a ton of really good tools
that can manage and move and convert
data that already exist so pandas is
really great CSV kit is a pretty great
tool if you're kind of world to CSV and
and you also have a unix environment
there's a southern tool called data set
which is really great for just working
with databases mostly postgres and then
there's this other tool down here that i
wanted to highlight called called daph
daph so really great tool if you have a
bunch of CSVs that you need to merge
together and there's a bunch of theirs
rows that are incomplete it basically
does a diff of your csv s and you can
select through it these top three tools
are written in python this one's written
a node so i guess there's that so this
is these problems kind of expand or they
go beyond just a single language a
single use case and then actually
there's a bunch of if you go on to
hacker news you go anywhere there's a
bunch of people that reject all tools
and say you should live entirely in UNIX
and you can do everything on the command
line two so James is quite deft at at
doing command line things you if you saw
it as talk you can potentially learn all
this and and collect all this inside of
your head
of how to do everything here so from cat
to tail and everything here with the
magic of pipe you can do a ton of
different things of your entire world is
flat file but you kind of have to be
creative there's not just it's not like
a one thing that does it you have to
fully grok each one of these tools and
all the Ark's associated with each one
of these things it's also quite a bit so
you still have problems so we'll start
with this was maybe the canonical
example of data munging if I need a CSV
I need to load it into memory right so
how do you go about doing that so if
you're you want to stay pip installable
so pandas I would argue is not exactly
pip installable but but well maybe now
it is with wheels so we'll just stay
entirely in Python so how would you
install how would you read into csv so
you call out to something that looks
like this you'd open up the file you
pass that into csv reader and then for
every line you call next on it and then
you'd manage and get money presumably
but actually what's happening here is
not it's not very useful because it's
just loading everything is in a string
so for every line that's their your ones
are stirs your one point to stir that's
not that's not how we actually work with
with data right so we call out to this
other this very popular concept data
frame just reading the CSV so they took
this idea I just want a single line just
the path to the file they read it in I
spent a little bit of time in numpy land
before before i came to pandas the load
text or load there was another one what
was the name of it Oh txt and there was
also something else but Jen from txt
yeah those ones didn't really work quite
well so you still had to you wanted to
take the CSV and you wanted to load it
into an umpire right tennis made that
really easy because it was already had
these concepts that record raised and
fully kind of work with and actually
people went kind of wild with inside of
this framework they realize oh I can do
a bunch of other stuff I want to take a
lot of different things and bring them
into data frame so our does this to a
lot of a lot of other tools to do this
but presumably we have this frame
work that we can now kind of push on we
can offload this problem on to other
people to say oh I want to also work
with excel so somebody else can write
the read from excel file and then I
think that calls out to XLR d or some
other underlying tool but me the the
developer the model or the data
scientist I don't really care what's
what's ingesting it that problems
already solved for me I just somebody
hands me excel files I can can read it
in we have all these other ones in here
so we get kind of esoteric message pack
maybe read from a pickle of a previously
pickled data frame we even have some
nice things down here read from C read
from sequel so i can write c grab a
sequel table and just bring it in we
also have these output functions too so
often we were in this we found ourselves
not we I mean the collective we find
ourselves in the situation where I pull
stuff out of whatever file it is
whatever database it is I do some
lunging I do some modeling and I need to
push it back in so somebody wrote how to
wrote these two methods and again that
problem was also offloaded onto a Dutch
of a bunch of other people we have this
framework we could write this to method
figure out what this data frame looks
like and then to CSV to excel to dicks
to sequel it's it's sort of solving that
that problem but you have to exist
entirely in the data frame in order for
this to work so how do you deal with a
pile of CSVs that's that's something
that you that I often that I'm handed a
folder of CSVs say do something with
this bring this into a data frame do you
do something that looks like this you
have a list your pen you grab a blob of
CSVs this case I might have lots of
Irish data so that'll be kind of like
the example throughout a lot of these
slides and then you append to this list
all these data frames and then at the
end you can cat right so Philip also is
a chord AB of pandas I asked him can I
just stick this function inside of
pandas why isn't as part of read CSV why
could I just hand it in addition to a
single file of CSV why can't I give him
a pile of CSVs and the answer is quite
reasonable it's like that's not that's
not kind of out of scope with within the
pandas world we do
is one thing really well let me do this
one read CSV really well and not not do
like 10 I mean have have anybody looked
at have you looked at the list of args
for read CSV it is extremely complete
because there are so many problems with
CSVs adding this load just seems kind of
unnecessary but now I have this function
and this is something that a lot of us
do we're all writing these like same
five lines of code would be nice if I
also had another framework where I could
codify these same five lines of code and
add it to the the general knowledge base
or actually remove it from the general
knowledge base just say here's a pile of
CSVs convert it to a data frame so take
this thing this glob wrap it in a
function may be read CS feature and now
I have this function that I can pass
around to all my friends they don't have
to worry about writing these five lines
anymore but this very simple I mean this
is just sort of a motivational case very
simple so codify this function of
framework this is what we do with odo so
odo can just take a pile of cs vs and
just call PD data frame and it gives you
back a data frame of all these things it
does the things that are a little bit
smarter than and what's right here but
that's generally the idea of of if you
look in the code base you'd see
something that's sort of looked a little
bit like this you take this pile of CSVs
you're reading them in it's actually
going to be a chunked reader and then
you just kind of caen cattle them
together and then you hand it back to it
to the user so we can take that concept
and extend it to lots of other things so
let's talk about databases so there's
DBA I think mahesh's DBA I so I've
worked with him in the past these are I
don't mean to be judgmental about some
of these things but the dba's life maybe
is filled with misery sometimes so the
my so the MS sequel the end of sequel BB
is maybe he's pretty sad or she said my
sequel person well they're so men to my
sequel is the most widely used database
in the world so say
Google I guess because that they use
that postgres people are generally
pretty happy they're kind of ecstatic
every you can do any you know postgres
people are always happy people [ __ ] DB
people are just like crazy so they're
super ecstatic I think I suppose like
I've heard people say disparaging things
about [ __ ] like it's it's a database
for JavaScript developers and then
oracle oracle people are also really
ecstatic if you live in oracle it
basically invented the database will not
invented it but they've just done
everything so so if you need if your
world is oracle you can do everything
inside of that database because it's
already been done the schema is already
written so overall you know DBA might
look like this but maybe we can learn
from that kind of misery you're not a
DBA so we don't expect that kind of melt
like if you need to write to a database
how do you do that are we going to push
that load back onto you as the as the
model or is the scientist statistician
of working with databases there's other
some of that some kind of sequel
fetching that we expect from from those
kinds of people oh that didn't work out
too well those are supposed to be more
emoticons so so you know you're not
you're not a happy person and again we
reference you know this the stack we're
trying to reduce reduce the pages in
this book so how do you how do we work
with the the naive way of working with
CSVs if we want to take a CSV and put it
into a database so so if we did this
with the iris example we grab a cursor
again we don't we don't have a DBA were
somebody within a larger organization
we're by ourselves so we have to create
a table then we have to we have to have
some function of read in the CSV all
that all the strings so maybe that's a
panda's read or maybe that's the Python
one and we have to do this insert into
the database but notice that we we
didn't get anything free we everything
had to be written everything had to be
understood about all the data everywhere
so you had to say so databases are
strongly typed actually sequel light is
not strongly it's not it doesn't enforce
types which does it you know can be
lovely so you can shove strings into NC
constructs put in some the strings and
will throw an error this this is not
great right so we want a tool that can
come
a lot of this knowledge so so pandas was
sort of going down has gone down this
route a little bit it does a read of the
CSV and then we have this to sequel so
we have we still have to create the
cursor the connection to the database we
handed a table name but the the data
frame has hanging off of it this to
sequel method so now so now i can if i
can get everything into a data frame i
know that i can easily push into this
into the DB so that's that's pretty
great so AutoCAD right odo can take a
pile of cs vs or a single csv convert it
to a data frame and I can push 222
sequel that's still kind of that's
that's not exactly what I want right
like under the hood there's there's a
lot of things happening the two sequel
does type conversion so it figures out
right as part of the data frame when you
load in in so it gives you hints and
then it also has to do a mapping of what
the numpy data types are so a numpy int
what does that convert to for the
database so is that so you so in sequel
it's calling sequel alchemy actually so
you so it grabs us from types sequel
alchemy has this very big type system
for all the different databases so for
Oracle you can be very specific but
those specifics of that type system is
different from postgres which is
different from my sequel and nothing as
we just heard kind of existence equal
light but it does this kind of mapping
of of an int or float in numpy world to
let that int and float are in DB world
it figures out the columns that you want
and then it does this chunk to insert
which is kind of nice did you have a
question sorry ok so if there's any
questions at any time please feel free
to interrupt but I know a DBA she said
oak loading is a thing so I have so
again I have this I have the CSV I want
to get to a database why am i reading in
two pandas just to get to a database
there's all these bulk loading methods
that I can take advantage of database
misery as is long and extensive I should
take advantage of all the misery that
they have gone through they went through
all the same things that CSV reader and
pandas and every other thing that had to
deal with CSV is long before us so when
you look at these copy methods each one
of them has the same sort of parameters
that you'd expect what's a little
annoying about this is that there isn't
kind of unification between all these
different databases i have to say copy
from for postgres and load data and bulk
insert actually this thing right here
bcp so the the Microsoft people long
time ago were like oh I often have to do
this thing where I take CSVs and put
them into databases all right a tool a
command-line tool called bulk copy it's
called bcp this is actually this came up
a little bit we were trying to rename
odo we're going to name it bcp and we
just happen to find it and even sequel
light has a bulk has a bulk loader it's
dot import if you're actually in the
show and it looks it looks a lot like
this so this this looks a lot like a lot
of the parameters that you have from
from read CSV you have a copy from a
table name the delimiter is whether
there's no characters the quote the
escape headers and coding all these
kinds of things are already built into
these bulk loaders wouldn't it be nice
if we just wrapped up this entire thing
inside of a function see where I'm going
with this so does that it takes in your
CSV it does a little bit of sipping of
what the data is looks that the first
couple lines figures out if there's a
header there but you can always pass in
some more information that there is a
header this is the encoding and then
when you call out to postgres you still
have to provide some off it just does a
bulk copy for you so not only have we
reduced the amount of lines that we have
to write from five to one we've reduced
the memory that we have to deal with
from whatever it is to read into a data
frame 20 this is i don't know like 20x
faster because it's written it's hard
coded into the database like it's
written as fast as
possibly can be we should be using those
kinds of things so CSV to DB oh right so
odo a framework for leveraging other
people's misery this is so if you're
miserable don't let other people be
miserable codify that knowledge and let
other people kind of move on with their
life but so if you let so I think Andy
two outs I saw saw he tweeted this out
as overheard I guess I don't know who
said it if you let people go to crazy
town they will every time so we can we
can do things like reading to see a
collection of CSVs into a database we
can take JSON blobs and put them into
[ __ ] right now there isn't you know if
you want to submit a PR postgres can
handle json submit a PR and we'll put
that in but this when i look at these
kinds of things this is just a uri it
makes this is the full uri that I could
possibly give it a username password
hostname port database table name that
you are I looks very familiar makes me
think about SSH things that I might want
to do I have a username a password and a
port so what stops me from using odo to
just copy to another machine there's
nothing so we did that that actually
becomes very useful it turns out because
if you are on Windows and you don't have
SCP installed how do you get your how do
you from the command line how do you
move things around or from the Python
prompt how do you move things around odo
can do that it's not it's not specific
to these eunuchs things I'm getting a
lot of weird looks but and that's
exactly right why do you why should we
be able to do this so it turns out it's
really useful if you ever need to deal
with remote machines so if you are
somebody that that's asked to say set up
a Hadoop cluster and you have this pile
of cs vs on your laptop which is
actually often the case if you're not
kind of like in production rolling
you're trying to get things up and
running you're often in this situation
where you have this i have some some
like example data here i need to push to
an HDFS cluster how do I get it on them
well maybe you live in a VPN where you
actually have ssh access
so I need to move it up there easily so
we now have this other mechanism of
moving things there we'll come back to
this but but essentially odo becomes
this place where I can do sort of a copy
from anywhere to anywhere as long as I
can write you know these these kinds of
functions so this is this is using para
Miko para Miko implements ssh2 protocols
that's why I can get it on windows and
anywhere else I don't have to call out
to unix SCP and I've now taken these
these three lines and I've wrapped it in
this function that takes in a CSV a text
file a JSON blob anything that I want
and it just sticks it on the machine now
the other nice thing about this is that
i can give it i can pass it i don't know
with SCP sometimes I forget whether or
not I can use the key file or if that's
arcing like arsenic has some weird
parameters where you have to like SSH in
but then our sink I was I don't know
maybe other people kind of keep that in
their head so let's talk about the cloud
I hate the cloud its tariffs it's a
terrible place so we invented this new
word there's not a DBA there's a data
engineer maybe I've seen seemed a couple
people that call for data engineers so
there's HDFS that that exists kind of as
this data engineer person or maybe a
Hadoop administrator there's a lot of
kind of lateral transitions between DBA
and HDA I guess there's s3 that's that's
a pretty popular place to store data and
there's redshift is also pretty great so
and there's these other things that we
rely on these other kind of weird
database or analytics engines like hives
and Impala so the HDFS person is pretty
unhappy every time I i need to put data
into HDFS what do i do so if i use a
command line tool like HDFS then i have
to write this really weird thing i have
to write HDFS DFS dash put the file that
i'm going to and then the the folder
there right its ass weird mapping but
that's really slow bay because HDFS is
implemented in Java so every time I want
to write from the command line just to
move a file i have to spin up a whole
JVM
that seems terrible that's like you
could do better you can do much better
than that the s3 person is pretty happy
actually because it's just I can put
whatever I want there it's just a key
value store and the redshift people are
also pretty happy too because it's just
postgres underneath we all have postgres
but then hive hives this weird analytics
engine it's a database that kind of
layers on top of on top of HDFS there
they're pretty unhappy because it's
doing it does a lot of very strange
things can be hard to deal with so hive
is this language where you can have is
both an analytics engine and this meta
story you write sequel it translates to
to a Java MapReduce job you get really
weird errors moving data in and around
HDFS can be strange if you kind of do a
delete if so high gives you this prompt
that's like a database prompt so if you
delete a table and hive what does that
mean for the underlying HDFS can be a
little confusing and Impala people I
think are there almost happy but Impala
depends on kind of the hive meta store
so they're not totally happy so overall
data engineers are unhappy and that's
because emoji algebra is really weird I
don't have time to go into it but you
know there's this various properties
that I couldn't do so so how do i get
from how do i move back and forth
between cloudy HDFS and data so we have
this pile of CSVs mmm i can write with
odo this one line i can say take this
pilot take the csv and put it into HDFS
the reason that I can do that is because
if you have eight web HDFS on your
cluster I can with HDFS gives me a non
JVM interface into HDFS and it has
primitives like read file and a pen file
so all that all web HDFS is just it's
just passing it's just a rest endpoint
and somebody nice enough to wrote this
Python interface for us that's that's
pretty wonderful if you don't have web
HDFS running on your cluster and I would
like to change this within the ODA
source source is this other tool called
snake bite which uses protobuf so again
you're still getting twenty percent
faster than just doing in HDFS put
or that's what they claim and I've also
seen things like that but now we can
kind of go crazy we've seen we can take
these small functions that we've seen
before we can codify this knowledge of
moving data in and out of s3 so if you
use bodo but it was a Python library
that where it has like things like set
key get key all these things i can move
data in and out of in and out of the in
and out of s3 buckets we move data in
that of HDFS I can even move data in an
in-between HDFS and hive since hi vis is
this sequel query like language it has
primitives while also like bulk loading
it's it has things like low data in path
it's it has very my sequel like
interface so you can say from from this
kind of folder of CSVs define this table
on top of it and this is something that
I was doing a lot because I wanted to
work with Impala and I'd have other
people that were on our teams wanted to
work with Impala see how fast we could
push it and even within within there's
some other parameters here that hive
also has things like stores parkade
stores avro store as our see are the
hive experts here maybe nothing so
nobody loves hive I love fried but and
then same thing with with redshift I can
also take this thing and push it into
redshift so actually now we're kind of
going really crazy our network is is
pretty big of things that I can do so
let's talk about binary stores so this
is this book of knowledge is pretty
pretty big but I actually maybe I should
pause just for a site so who here works
with binary stores like hdf5 or b calls
mpz files so there's a few people are
you scientific programmers general yeah
maybe some academics that work with
those things so there's these this whole
other world of binary stores that are
very popular amongst like the academic
proud physics people use them they don't
they don't ever work with database is
very rarely do they do they they they
work with these things called hdf5 and B
calls
maybe parkade and generally these people
are super ecstatic these files they're
small binary files they're portable
their tabular some of them columnar the
compressible their chunked I can do all
these really amazing things with these
binary stores that I can't do Li do I
don't need a whole database to do these
kinds of things so that maybe there's
some knowledge gaps between the web
world and the scientific compute world
and they go both ways but there's still
problems here so hdf5 has had some
issues there's a couple different
interfaces into it so there's that
there's pie tables which is pretty great
interface into hdf5 there's if anybody
uses HTTP 5 within pandas there's this
specialized HDFS store which you can't
just read from PI tables so pandas does
something special I think Phillip
Phillip was telling me before it's
because there's no there's no date time
type in n hdf5 so you have to convert
your date times in two int's and then
there's no barling strings so so you're
kind of hosed on that and then be calls
actually is this new thing but it
doesn't solve missing data there's some
rough edges and it's still new but if
you do array oriented computing or if
all of your data can be kind of
vectorized or just five minutes left
I've minute left okay I took too long
and there's another thing called parquet
but there's no Python interface to it
but party is really popular in the
Impala world it's really popular to take
all this HDFS data and see if you can
compress it may get columnar now you can
do really fast selections so think for
for as much hype is there's around spark
if you can live in this world that's
just sequel like functions kind of joins
and merges and and and group buys parque
and an impala are pretty pretty pretty
impressive so overall the binary store
people maybe they were super ecstatic
but there's still some issues so so Oh
towed again takes care of this problem I
can move in and out between all these
different kind of binary stores I can go
in addition to all these seats all these
conversions I can also go from from data
frames and umpire arrays there's some
places where this is going to break
file a bug report and we'll fix it but
but it's but it's pretty great so how
does all this work do I have to write I
think that's been getting man from so so
I can do this right now I can do this I
can take a nest wreath I can take
something in s3 and I can shove it into
a postgres DB that can be really great
if i'm running a bunch of if i'm running
giant batch jobs i shove all the data
baton back into s3 but i don't want my
web front end to be s3 i want my web
front end to be postgres i need to get
the data back out do i have to write
every single conversion for every
possible path the answer is no but the
answer I don't know why it says yes Oh
does this work yet there we go okay so
the question was does this work so the
answer is yes how how so actually it
works like this so this is all the
possible paths that everything can take
so if i hover over one of these things
like odo csv the out links are in green
the in links are in red so from odo csv
i can go to everything here so
underneath the covers actually is this
network ex management of all these
different endpoints and you find the
smallest path between one node and
another and you write conversions
between them so we saw a couple of those
conversions before that's just the
function that I'm going to take from
from a.csv to a data frame and then
there's also these how do I move data
around it's just appending in one place
to another so that HDFS append file so
here's a I've got like 20 minutes left
but here's how here's how you might you
go about doing this thing so I had this
so often I also is in this case where
it's like here's a CSV file out on the
web right there's an endpoint called a
half and it was like sword on a github
repo so it's I first had to remember it
so yeah raw github user content all the
sing and here's a here's an endpoint put
that into a data frame it's actually not
not such a new idea to be able to say
call out to some web endpoint and stick
that in a data frame pandas already does
this so you can call it to yahoo and
Google and just pull that right into a
data frame you can do this with other
kind of finance resources but I wanted
to do it for for all these CSVs and JSON
files had lived everywhere and I was
getting very tired of right clicking or
downloading to the download folder only
just to put it into a data frame that's
all that I want to do with it then I
have all these latent files I need to
clean up and then they're not big
they're just kind of like adding to this
larger pile of misery that I was
experiencing like I just have files kind
of everywhere it was very annoying so so
i can solve this with odo because i can
go to crazy town and nobody's stopping
me so there's four functions but there's
really there's really five functions and
the four functions that I need to
implement inside of Oh know or discover
convert a pending and resource so
they're very simple I mean in terms of
at least explaining what they are so
discover just figures up is going to be
the type system convert is how I move
from one type to another append is how I
get data from one location to another
and then resources how I kind of codify
what that you are I looks like and then
drop is this optional one where I can
kind of delete it so i can drop a table
i can delete a file you can't drop the
URL obviously so so here's how i do it
right this is just the small function
this is actually taken right from the
codebase just open up the the URL and
then write it to a file i discover is
something that i get free from data
shape so i sip a little bit of data and
then i just try and discover on what
those types are sorry i'm just trying to
go fast but i can just because i guess
i'm holding up lunch convert often is
just about getting in see this temporary
location so if i go back to hear if i
get the the sort of promised that we try
to make is so i have this URL and it's
it's a URL csv type sort of i can go
into that but if the promise that this
network tries to give is if i can get
from any other node into this network i
can get anywhere else so from URL csv if
i can get to a temp csv it's just this
thing that we've codified within odo
saying just store to a temporary file
when you're done using that resource
garbage collected and delete it
and then get anywhere else so from a URL
I can go to a data frame I can go to
HDFS I can go to s3 I can go to ssh you
can do all these things if I provide the
right parameters so that's what I did or
yeah that's what what which what you can
do now as well as take URL and put it
right into a data frame take URL put it
right into HDFS so here's just some last
closing thoughts so frameworks are great
right learn learn my abstraction and
your life will be easier is kind of
generally how I think about frameworks I
odo maybe is this place where i can
write a very small function i can move
and convert data at that hopefully that
misery is kind of gone from my life
there's a lot for as much science as
there isn't data science or computer
science there's still a lot of folklore
out their databases require dbas that's
not that's not really true anymore you
can you can install you know if you're
doing something small if you're just a
small research group you're not doing
transactional data you need to work with
it you need to do like efficient joins
or things like that databases are really
powerful you should be using them
another one that I alluded to earlier is
that there's kind of this general
knowledge that [ __ ] sucks you should go
try it it's really easy somebody shaking
their head but you should like we I my
knowledge is dependent on kind of what
somebody else told me somebody told me
[ __ ] sucks and I've kind of repeated
that we can verify those things very
easily now it might suck for you but it
might not suck for these other people
and then there's some other things
there's these gaps in knowledge like the
academics and the scientific computing
people like know about these binary
stores why don't other people you should
use those kinds of things you can do a
lot of really great work you write a
whole website off of a single sequel
light file that's trans that's not a
binary store but that's extremely
portable p calls maybe is also a place
where you can run a whole website but
you can do a lot of if your data is just
a bunch of vectors you could do a lot of
reading from that and just shove that
into some JSON and you can do that
without it's not too bad so ultimately
is place for happy people it's not so
miserable
yeah yeah I think I'm done okay thanks